every time you smoke a cigarette toxic
gases pass into your lungs then into
your bloodstream where they spread to
every organ in your body
a cigarette is made using the tobacco
leaf which contains nicotine and a
variety of other compounds
as the tobacco and compounds burn they
release thousands of dangerous chemicals
including over 40 known to cause cancer
cigarette smoke contains the poisonous
gases carbon monoxide and nitrogen oxide
as well as trace amounts of
cancer-causing radioactive particles
all forms of tobacco are dangerous
including cigars pipes and smokeless
tobacco such as chewing tobacco and
snuff
nicotine is an addictive chemical in
tobacco after you inhale tobacco smoke
nicotine flows through the bloodstream
to your brain where it induces a
pleasurable feeling when you repeatedly
expose your brain to nicotine it becomes
desensitized making you crave more and
more nicotine just to feel normal
smoking causes death people who smoke
typically die at an earlier age than
non-smokers in fact one of every five
deaths in the United States is linked to
cigarette smoking if you smoke your risk
of major health problems increases
dramatically including heart disease
heart attack stroke lung cancer and
death from chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease
smoking causes cardiovascular disease
teen flows through your adrenal glands
it stimulates the release of epinephrine
a hormone that raises your blood
pressure
in addition nicotine and carbon monoxide
can damage the lining of the inner walls
in your arteries fatty deposits called
plaque can build up at these injury
sites and become large enough to narrow
the arteries and severely reduce blood
flow resulting in a condition called
atherosclerosis
in coronary artery disease
atherosclerosis narrows the arteries
that supply the heart which reduces the
supply of oxygen to your heart muscle
increasing your risk for a heart attack
smoking also raises your risk for blood
clots because it causes platelets in
your blood to clump together
smoking increases your risk for
peripheral vascular disease in which
atherosclerosis block the large arteries
in your arms and legs smoking can also
cause an abdominal aortic aneurysm which
is a swelling or weakening of your aorta
where it runs through your abdomen
smoking damages two main parts of your
lungs your Airways also called bronchial
tubes and small air sacs called alveoli
with each breath air travels down your
windpipe called the trachea and enters
your lungs through your bronchial tubes
air then moves into thousands of tiny
alveoli where oxygen from the air moves
into your bloodstream and the waste
product carbon dioxide moves out of your
bloodstream
tiny hairlike projections called cilia
line your bronchial tubes and sweep
harmful substances out of your lungs
cigarette smoke irritates the lining of
your bronchial tubes causing them to
swell and make mucus
cigarette smoke also slows the movement
of your cilia causing some of the smoke
and mucus to stay in your lungs
while you are sleeping some of the cilia
recover and start pushing more
pollutants and mucus out of your lungs
when you wake up your body attempts to
expel this material by coughing
repeatedly a condition known as smokers
coughs over time chronic bronchitis
develops as your cilia stop working your
Airways become clogged with scars and
mucus and breathing becomes difficult
your lungs are now more vulnerable to
further disease
cigarette smoke also damages your LVL I
making it harder for oxygen and carbon
dioxide to exchange with your blood over
time so little oxygen can reach your
blood that you may develop emphysema a
condition in which you must gasp for
every breath and wear an oxygen tube
under your nose in order to breathe
chronic bronchitis and emphysema are
collectively called chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease or COPD COPD is a
gradual loss of the ability to breathe
for which there is no cure
cigarette smoke contains at least 40
cancer-causing substances called
carcinogens including cyanide
formaldehyde benzene and ammonia
in your body healthy cells grow make new
cells then die genetic material inside
each cell called DNA directs this
process
if you smoke toxic chemicals can damage
the DNA in your healthy cells
as a result your damaged cells create
new unhealthy cells which grow out of
control and may spread to other parts of
your body
the most common cancer in the world is
lung cancer with over a million new
cases diagnosed every year
harmful chemicals in cigarettes can
cause cancer in other parts of your body
such as in the blood and bone marrow
mouth larynx throat esophagus stomach
pancreas kidney bladder uterus and
cervix
smoking can cause infertility in both
men and women
if a woman is pregnant and smokes during
pregnancy she exposes her baby to the
cigarettes poisonous chemicals causing a
greater risk of low birth weight
miscarriage preterm delivery stillbirth
infant death and sudden infant death
syndrome
smoking is also
Duras if a mother is breastfeeding
nicotine passes to the baby through
breast milk and can cause restlessness
rapid heartbeat vomiting interrupted
sleep or diarrhea
other health effects of smoking include
low bone density and increased risk for
hip fracture among women gum disease
often leading to tooth loss and surgery
immune system dysfunction and delayed
wound healing and sexual impotence in
men